bonsoir d'il divo merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france la
phase iii donc une nouvelle très une
étape très importante pour votre
traitement anti qu'ovide les espérances
sont grandes
bah oui les expériences les espérances
parents sont évidemment très grand
bonsoir à tous nous savons que
malheureusement il n'existe toujours pas
de traitement actif pour guérir les gens
qui souffrent notamment des phases
aggravé de covile 19
alors bien sûr comme vous venez de
souligner la vaccination constitue un
énorme espoir pour réduire le nombre de
personnes qui auront besoin d'être
traités mais il reste des malades
il en restera malheureusement toujours
et pour ces gens là un espoir de
traitement c'est indispensable
donc qu'est ce que c'est qu'une phase
iii c'est une phase quantitative où on a
déjà 400 passion donc on est déjà sur un
grand nombre de patients qui nous permet
d'être confiants et là nous allons
rajouter un essai sur 722 patients qui
va se dérouler dans toute l'europe
alors on va parler de ce fameux
traitement parce que c'est vrai qu'on en
a pas beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps
on a laissé là par malo part belle aux
vaccins on laisse un petit peu de côté
ces traitements ils font partie des
anticorps polyclonaux qu'est ce que
c'est exactement alors c'est un
anticorps dirigés contre le virus alors
l'avantagé comme il est polyclonale il
marche contre les variants alors vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui les variants c'est
un vrai souci parce qu'on sait que les
enfants des autres anticorps qu'on
appelle monoclonaux e pour le coup
présente vraiment un risque de
d'inactivation totale avec les variants
les polyclonaux ne subissent pas ce
risque là donc c'est un anticorps il va
détruire le virus
il va neutraliser le virus et en plus il
va avoir un effet très spécifiques de
notre technologie puisqu'il va limiter
l'inflammation liée au virus
au total nous espérons bien qu'il
permettra de guérir les gens qui sont
dans la phase dite modérée
ça veut dire quoi exactement d'il divo
la phase dite modérée ça veut dire si on
vous suit que quel que soit le variés
du virus qu'on attrape brésilien
sud-africain britannique euros on peut
une fois qu'on est testé positif prendre
ce traitement alors le principe de notre
traitement c'est que quand vous le savez
quand on attrape lakovic 19 on commence
par une phase qui est relativement
bénigne et qui heureusement rarement
risque de s'aggraver alors la phase
bénigne allure en bo5 jour et au vième
entre le 6e et le neuvième jour
précisément là il ya un risque de
démarrer une pneumopathie
c'est à ce moment là que le g 19 prend
toute sa place puisqu'il va empêcher
cette phase
au moment de cette phase d'aggravation
il va empêcher le risque de passer à une
phase beaucoup plus grave on risque
d'aller en réanimation ou en soins
intensifs
donc il est destiné à des gens qui
aujourd'hui pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur sont de 1500 à 2000 personnes
par jour en france qui auraient besoin
d'un traitement comme le 19 donc c'est
un besoin qui est relativement limitée
par rapport au nombre de cas que nous
voyons tous les jours encore
malheureusement mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que c'est un besoin réel pour les
patients qui sont dans les hôpitaux
ça veut dire qu'une fois qu'on a été
vaccinée on peut tout de même prendre ce
traitement ou ça ne sert à rien alors ça
c'est un grand mystère puisque le sujet
c'est l'efficacité le sujet que vous
soulevez c'est l'efficacité de la
vaccination
donc on sait aujourd'hui que la
vaccination empêche la plupart des gens
d'arriver à un stade très grave de la
maladie
c'est les premiers essais cliniques qui
l'on est et qui ont l'ont démontré
notamment aux états unis
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'on est
encore en pas en mesure absolue de
savoir si les gens qui sont vaccinées
peuvent malgré tout tomber malade et se
retrouver nos stades dits modérés ou là
il sera tout à fait intéressant de
suppléer
propres anticorps par le graph 19 donc
ça c'est quelque chose que nous ignorons
pour l'instant en tout cas nous nous
avons dans nos essais cliniques recruté
par a proposé les 1,19 à des gens qui
étaient en début de spécialisation
qu'ils soient vaccinées ou non et ça
fera partie des choses que nous
étudierons lorsque nous découvrons les
résultats de l'essai alors la question
se pose pourquoi cet essai se
déroule-t-il en grèce en bulgarie en
roumanie en espagne en turquie et pas en
france alors que vous êtes une société
française
alors on est une société française on a
démarré donc notre projet graff 19 en
mars 2020 nous avons donc était prêt
pour la clinique dès le mois de mai 2020
parce que notre technologie était très
mature et donc nous avons ensuite fort
naturellement proposé aux autorités
françaises de faire un essai clinique en
france et c'est ce qui a été fait et qui
a été d'ailleurs soutenu par le
gouvernement en association avec le
siège nantes qui a fait un travail
remarquable de promotion et de
mobilisation de 35 hôpitaux en france et
avec l'université de nantes
les français laissait polycor 400
patients vient de finir ses recrutements
et en parallèle le cei nous a semblé
naturel
en plus nous avions eu un financement
européen de proposer à d'autres pays en
europe qui ont aussi des pratiques
thérapeutiques et d'hospitalisation
différente de voir qu'elle pouvait être
l'intérêt sur d'autres pays donc ce
n'est pas que nous ne sommes pas en
france c'est que au delà de la france
nous faisons un essai dans d'autres pays
pour vous donner une idée dans certains
pays les infrastructures hospitalières
étant différente
les personnes qui aujourd'hui en france
sont hospitalisées pour être surveillés
même si elles ne sont pas dans un état
grave vont dans d'autres pays être
renvoyée chez elle est simplement
surveiller à distance par des coups de
téléphone journalier donc les pratiques
sont différentes et nous pensons que
pour ces malades aussi par exemple c'est
extrêmement intéressant de recevoir 19
19 d'où l'intérêt de faire un essai dans
d'autres pays
est ce que vous avez
déjà reçu des précommandes
la commission européenne qui on le sait
j'ai re voilà il centralise les
commandes pour l'union européenne
alors nous avons eu des discussions avec
ce qui sera la future agence européenne
des épidémies donc l'équivalent du barda
américain nous avons eu des discussions
depuis quelques semaines sur le sujet
mais nous n'avons à ce stade pas signé
de précommande avec la commission
européenne
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres pays avec
lesquels vous auriez signé des commandes
j'ai pas si vous voyez où je veux en
venir mais c'est vrai qu'on entendait le
pdg de modern à nous dire assez tôt en
amont que voilà il s'étonner pas avoir
eu de commandes de son vaccin moderna
qui fonctionnait déjà et qui étaient
commandés surtout au royaume uni et aux
états unis et aucune commande en europe
as construit lui même chemin avec votre
traitement ou est ce que la commission
européenne s'est améliorée entre temps
alors écoutez il ne m'appartient pas de
juger les évolutions et les progrès de
la commission européenne cela certains
moi ce que je peux te dire vue de la
fenêtre d'une biotech c'est que et
peut-être que c'est un peu le cas de
modern a aussi c'est que quand on est
une entreprise relativement jeunes avec
des ressources aussi limité en nombre
on n'est pas en mesure de faire j'allais
dire une action commerciale de
proposition vis-à-vis de toutes les
structures du monde entier nous
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une phase
du médicament extrêmement pour un jambe
qui fait que nous avons un certain
nombre de gens qui nous contactent pour
pouvoir nous réserver du médicament etc
des sujets sur lesquels nous avançons
pas à pas j'avais dire et sont beaucoup
plus en mesure de communiquer dans les
prochains mois il est certain que en
tant que biotech française soutenue et
financée largement par le gouvernement
français et par l'europe depuis le
démarrage du projet coheed moins que
d'autres mais quand même de façon
significative nous pouvons moi il me
semble normal de proposer en priorité
notre traitement au gouvernement
l'europe donc c'est ce que nous avons
fait et c'est pour ça que nous
privilégions à la discussion avec
l'europe
indépendamment des demandes qui ne sont
fait d'autres parties du monde
aujourd'hui clairement dit le du bo vous
avez les moyens de produire de manière
industrielle alors nous avons fait un
énorme effort chez xénon terrain pour
vous dire on était quand même moins
d'ici un an on est pratiquement 20
aujourd'hui on va grossi fit alors ça
peut sembler encore très peu nombreux et
puis surtout nous avons des partenaires
et notamment un partenaire français qui
est le lfb qui est impliqué dans le
manufacturing et avec lequel nous avons
travaillé sur l'industrialisation de
l'ensemble de nos procédés le but étant
effectivement de pouvoir couvrir les
besoins du marché avec une phase
d'industrialisation extrêmement rapide
en gros pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
à partir de janvier 2022
les lots donc les groupes de deux
médicaments sont fraîches accrue de
médicaments sera quasiment 100 fois plus
gros que ce que faisait en 2020 donc on
aura multiplié notre échelle de
production par cent ce qui est
absolument colossal et qui dans pour une
industrie pharmaceutique représentent
des efforts de validation de l'ensemble
des étapes du procédé qui sont loin
d'être négligeables
techniquement ce n'est pas ça une toute
dernière question les résultats donc la
phase 2 1 fin juin 6
c'était contenu quand est ce que oui
quand est ce qu'on peut espérer voir ce
traitement sur le marché alors alors ça
ne dépend pas que douvin ça dépend aussi
des agences et notamment de l'année
celle donc nous commençons à dialoguer
avec l'année celle de façon à pouvoir
dès l'obtention des résultats être en
mesure de proposer ce traitement et
notamment au cours des patients de la
pac du mois d'automne que j'espère aussi
plate que possible que ce soit bien
faire merci beaucoup du veau présidente
de xénon terra d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france